avnith morty and her parents try to
figure out how to recover the nearly 12
thousand dollars they've lost in
tertiary education fees in canada the
college of neeth was supposed to go to
in montreal as one of three which
declared bankruptcy this month and
closed i'm in a big mess right now
because it was my father's money he
earned a lot
with some hard work and now i'm like i
have wasted all that money because i
forced my father that i want to go
abroad and want to study i want to live
freedomly independently
23 year old avenith and others like her
in cities throughout punjab have been
protesting and appealing to the indian
government to help them get a refund the
government in quebec province is
investigating the admission practices of
the three colleges which shut down
another 10 colleges were suspended last
year while investigators checked whether
they were admitting international
students who didn't meet english
language requirements and also squeezing
the mandatory 20 study hours a week into
two to three days so that students could
find a job for the rest of the week
sending students abroad is big business
in india with agents taking hefty
commissions from students fees more than
500 000 indian students travel abroad
for their tertiary studies every year
but researchers say less than a third
are admitted to established universities
the others go to what are considered
substandard colleges in their attempts
to get citizenship
or they're deceived by people posing as
education agents
al jazeera requested an interview with
our meets agency but they refused so you
don't need an agent police in the city
of patiala told al jazeera that the
desire to go overseas makes many fall
for false promises rather than doing
their own research verify the
credentials
of the agents or the
educational institutes that are claiming
that they'll get you
employment or they'll get you admission
in the colleges and
universities abroad
but immigration and education
consultants who are accredited by
foreign governments say the problem is
that anyone is allowed to start a study
abroad agency in india
having a license doesn't mean that this
person is qualified license only means
your premises have been identified as
having an office there's no checking of
qualifications by the government to see
if someone is capable of doing the work
valverde and many others are calling on
the indian government to regulate the
massive industry while of nathan
thousands like her try to get their
family's life savings back elizabeth
peradam al jazeera patiala punjab